>>Daniel Goleman: It
may surprise you to know
that attention is like a muscle.
Like a muscle in the arm, and that
there are exercises, mental exercises
that can improve attention that
strengthen the brain circuitry
for attention just like you'd go
to the gym and you'd do some reps
on a CYBEX machine and
get a stronger tricep.
These exercises are very
simple, but very effective.
The social emotional
learning curricula have many
that are developmentally appropriate
so that you teach the same lesson
in different ways as children's
cognitive abilities expand
with brain growth and as
they go through the grades.
One of the most effective is
something called "The Stoplight."
It's a poster on the
wall of a classroom.
It says, "When you're upset, remember
the stoplight, red light, stop,
calm down, think before you act,
yellow light, think of a range
of different things you could do
now and what the outcome would be.
Green light, pick the best one.
You can try it.
It's a highly effective method.